um what's been up man how was your uh
how was the halloween weekend
oh man it was fantastic i gotta say
oh wow what uh did you dress up what
happened no i didn't dress up
i just hung out with a few friends at um
at their apartment just hung out at
night
well that sounds kind of uh um
what would i it sounds kind of moulin
rouge a little bit you hung out at night
who was this group was it just
so yes it was a friend of mine um
and his girlfriend and then his
girlfriend's
friend from back at home in memphis oh
dang so it was a quad was it a
quattuplet or whatever four of you
yeah okay nice man and um
what did you guys get into anything fun
uh we did a few drinking games um
everyone tried to get me drunk and it
was great
um and what's your preferred drink of
choice
man there's something called a chauffeur
hofer which is
um it's a german drink they have all
these different flavors my favorite is
the grapefruit
because my my buddy back at home andrew
he's
he's german and he actually gave me that
as my first
drink to have and that's my favorite
all-time drink damn favorite all time
baby um nice man
uh what else has been going on anything
else um
i mean i had i had my uh
i had a first a lot of firsts i should
say
really like what do you mean like a
like a try to guess okay um
well you said you'd had a drink before
so i'm guessing it's not your first
drink
nope let me think your first um
doing fireworks or something nope i've
always i've always done fireworks
on fourth of july amen bro not that um
your first you and you don't do drugs
right i don't
huh
what happened um let's just say i had
i had a first uh interaction with the
lady
what bro you mean like uh like what do
you mean like first
like are we talking sex i guess are we
talking um okay
no no no okay sorry maybe i'll jump into
the conclusions there and that was
i'm obviously a [ __ ] but um no you're
good uh
what so first kiss maybe
yep bingo no way yeah
it was it was great it was a good time
no what
and so what happened take me through
some of that you got this so
this is what the your buddy's
girlfriend's friend
buddy's girlfriend's friend yes um yeah
so she
is from the west west side of tennessee
and she came by
and so we were just hanging out and it
was great and
when you saw her at first and you know
there was any interest or no no i
i didn't think of anything at all uh
that was the weird part and so i mean
actually that was the normal part for me
of course and i was like okay you know
you know she's friends you know whatever
so we were hanging out having a good
time
and there are some times where like so
let me skip forward a little my uh my
buddy joe he
texted me because we were all sitting
next to each other so he texted me he
was like hey dude
look at the signs and he was like yeah
dude that's all i'm gonna say
i was like hmm so i've been thinking
past
like that was later that night so i was
thinking all the other
like hours in the night and i was like
um that totally makes sense so i was
like okay
oh it all came it all made sense at that
point right that juncture
right called a juncture and yeah so
we ended up watching nightmare before
christmas and i i was
i was kind of drunk i was like not
feeling great and
so she was like yeah do you want to sit
on the couch and i was like yeah
that would probably be great so she took
my hand so she took the lead it sounds
like
she did but the thing is when she took
my hand she didn't take it you know like
you know just holding on to me or
whatever grabbed my arm or whatever
no she literally did the full on like
closed hand you probably can't see it
because of the monitor but yeah i can't
see it
it's um that guy oh wow the full closed
hand thing
and interlocking fingers and i was like
hmm
okay um i can roll with this
so then you guys are sitting on the
couch so yeah we were sitting on the
couch and it was it was all four of us
we were watching nightmare before
christmas
and were you nervous i am at well at
that point i was like okay you know this
is
this is fine i didn't think anything
about like you know first kiss or
anything like that
so i was like okay you know i was
totally fine like you know she
she was comforting me it was great she
was cuddling with me slowly
more and more and i was like hmm okay
i'm liking this dang
boy and something erect bro
so then my um uh
my my friend joe and his girlfriend they
went down to pick up some cookout
from one of my friends that brought it
for us now that's always the moment bro
when
when the other couple leaves the room
suddenly
the heat is on right
he took his girl with him yeah he took
his girl with him and i knew what he was
getting
at of course man that's broco [ __ ] bro
so then after they left we were talking
a little bit
and then yeah we just yeah she made the
first move and it was great
yeah a lot of firsts for me i gotta say
cause that's also a first
her making the first move wow
and so how long did it last
quite some time i gotta say yeah
[Applause]
the just lockwood ellipse over here dang
bro and so
was there any like was it did you guys
just kiss for while i'm in separate was
there like a snuggle
at night or what was this it was a
snuggle it was a nice snuggle i got a
thing
were you pretty drunk at that time no i
wasn't
and did you get drunk no okay no
so i know for a fact it was definitely
real it was definitely something not
just
drunkenness so did you get her number
what's the deal man i have her number
instagram snapchat all that you have
mail
um and yeah it was
it was a lot of fun so she's back at
home but i've been texting her back and
forth
so wow you think there's something up
maybe
possibly yeah yeah we were talking about
it uh maybe but she's coming back
um i think she is oh yeah uh she comes
back
to nashville about once a month i found
out so
it's suddenly how suddenly they come
back once a month you know
it's just the old it's the way it is man
exactly wow
riley mal you're growing up brother
first kiss ever huh
yeah yeah i was pretty excited it was a
great time
dude that's awesome man
that's awesome man and it was she a
redhead
maybe how how'd you know
i just fit is she really yeah i just
felt it man
oh well yeah i just felt it
yep she is amen man
well we'll see man it's probably
downhill from here overall i'm just
saying it's you know it's
i mean it's uphill but it's right it
gets to be a rocky road brother
true you know there's adult tree there's
all kind of stuff but
but you're just starting out man and
that's what's important dude i'm happy
for you man
good evening good afternoon and other
times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw i mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better what if you watch a video
right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one
ah